I started acting when I was when I was
10 years old I booked a little show
called castle I heard that you're a fan
I'm a huge fan and I actually remember
this yeah it was so good but my
character's name I had a one episode
guest star role biggest I was so proud
of it I ran in one of the characters I
was like I ran up to him my name was
Timmy in the show of course a little kid
named Timmy shocker
I ran up to him and I was like Uncle
Harvey you want to see my baseball cards
and that was your moment that was my big
moment first of all you are hilarious
you are so funny yeah you're like a
walking party so you're on blackish so
who's the most surprising fan that
you've met the most surprising fan I've
met huh what about that okay so let me
start by saying this we got to go to the
White House for the Easter Egg Roll a
couple years back okay I know you guys
can see where this is going
it's pretty good from here but we got to
go to the White House for the Easter Egg
Roll I've got to bring my entire family
went to the went to the Oval Office
bathroom that there there paper towels
are literally like real towels no the
bathroom was the coolest part it was
like marble all over the place I was
like whoa those people are like
fascinated by the-- yeah no but the
bathroom was
[Applause]
yeah we got to meet Michelle and Barack
Obama it was an amazing day if you pay
close attention you can see my arm isn't
around Michelle because I was like is
this illegal am I allowed to put my arm
around Michelle Obama like service she's
gonna like jump out of the roof and like
I think you chose wisely awkwardly
standing you know 14-year old Marcus
just like subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel please
don't make me keep going